um welcome buddy happy monday oh look
likewise i mean it's a beautiful day out
there so
very happy to be here with you guys and
everyone joining delighted to see people
from all over
now i didn't know this but you already
said it to me this
it was eddie's birthday on the weekend
everybody so can everyone please just
give him a bit of a hip hip hooray in
the chat room right now
uh and give eddie a wonderful birthday
message uh also because he's
he's up bright and early this morning
like all school teachers would be though
right all teachers
for sure i mean at my school uh you know
not every teacher has this class but our
morning class which i often teach
um starts at half past seven so you know
that's that's when you're meant to be in
the classroom and the bell goes
so before then is when you sort of
arrive and get yourself settled
now you teach us i'm going off topic
already
but you teachers work very very hard but
i always thought that youth teachers had
it easy as well with your holidays
you know the amount of holidays that you
get but you might there's a lot of
effort that goes in
involved in planning classes and getting
classes ready isn't that correct
yeah for sure and i think you know
probably work in every industry you know
we
i think this is such a human psychology
thing right we compare the hard things
of our own work with the easy things we
see in others
um so i expect you know i've got friends
who are um you know they work in
hospitality or their work in medicine
and
every profession has its challenges but
for sure like the
the term break that we have from school
um usually for me that's full of things
like marking
lesson planning um preparing different
resources and assessment tasks all that
kind of thing
um and to be fair like i enjoy that it's
hard work um but it is really important
to help students learn
um but it is it is tough so making sure
that we keep well balanced and you know
have our
eye on mental well-being which i think
is something which is really important
for us today
is really central so good we just seen a
few messages pop up damien's a local
cherry book boy so he grew up in the
area
uh samantha her kids knew about eddie
before she did
uh their maths teacher advised uh their
classes to watch eddie online there we
go eddie making
you're already making a difference and
today we're just gonna we're gonna
unpack it a little bit we're gonna
um we wanna know a little bit more
around your history and and where you
grew up and all that type of stuff so
obviously um your parents arrived in
australia when did they arrive
so early 70s really and that and uh they
both they both came to australia
um slightly independently um and decided
you know they came from the
malaysia and um having a chinese
background um was challenging to them
for a bunch of different reasons
malaysian society
is really built around the indigenous
people
both politically and economically as
well and
in terms of education they knew they'd
have much more opportunity
for us growing up me my brother my
sister who hadn't been born
yet were all born here um they knew they
would have so many more opportunities
if australia was the place that they
made their home that's so good mate and
growing up in oz back
when you've you know early days uh
you've been noted to say that you know
you you got bullied a little bit and
stuff like that
um do you think that gave you a bit of
grounding in life as well or do you
yeah yeah yeah absolutely i mean
um growing up in suburban sydney in the
in the 80s and 90s um that was you know
let's let's be really clear it was
certainly
something where i was comfortable i was
i was you know provided with so many
opportunities
but at the same time i looked very
different from everyone around me
and so you know at school is kind of
like well this is the what's this kid
who is who are they and i think
it's fairly natural for young children
to be a little bit suspicious of those
who don't look or sound like us
but i kind of had this sort of double
whammy because didn't feel like i
belonged here in australia um those
few times that i actually went with my
family back to where my family came from
from malaysia
um i didn't belong there either because
you can hear from my voice
actually it's one of the funniest things
on my youtube channel people like what
accent is that i've got no idea it's
very confusing
to see the mismatch right it's like the
first time i saw kevin rudd speaking
fluent mandarin i was like something
doesn't look right
it definitely didn't feel like i
belonged back in that culture either so
i guess that is kind of the nature of
being a second generation immigrant
well mate you've achieved a lot already
in uh your career and we'll get into you
know how you became
the wutube sensation that you are but um
2018 was a big year for you yeah like
you hosted the show
teenage boss on the abc uh you delivered
a ted talk
uh you were named australia's local hero
award
um which i think you know you can even
be testament to that
but you're the top 10 finalists in the
global teacher price that's pretty
incredible too that
that's pretty epic it was particular
right
yeah look it was it was it was banana to
be honest um so the global teacher prize
is this um well as the name suggests
it's this
education uh award that is uh for people
internationally there's like something
like 40 or 50 000 people who apply every
single year
um and someone who i work with said hey
you should you should put in an
application
and after i stopped laughing at her i
was like if like for real
um they said no no we're really serious
about it you know you never know
what it is that um you know might
inspire someone else and i think that
like you said mentioned before it was
the fact that i put a lot of
effort and time into making my teaching
available to people
online which is really delightful to see
people in the chat who's like oh the
kids know about
me through there so i just kind of you
know
read a bit of an application hit send
and didn't really think about it very
much
and then for them to then you know come
knocking on the door say hey can we have
like a a skype chat with you at like 9pm
at night because they're based in london
and to tell me hey you're in the top 10
um it just
it was a really surreal experience it
didn't feel it still
feels bizarre to be honest what other
teachers were in the top 10 was it like
english and
like is or is it just space around math
uh no no it's it's all around the world
of all different subjects and
i should point out the amazing
incredible woman
who won a british teacher named andrea
zafaraku she's an art and textiles
teacher
and just yeah an incredible woman she
works in a um
a fairly disadvantaged area in london
with lots of
refugees and she speaks like 15
different languages because of all the
different communities that she serves
so yeah from all over the world um one
of the previous winners she's from
canada
um up near like the arctic circle she
works with um inuit people in a
in a little town you can't reach by road
you've got you're going to fly there
so it was incredible being honored among
those uh amazing people
you know like we were chatting about
this we we ran a week with cure cancer
and the incredible researchers that are
out there trying to
find um you know uh cures for cancer etc
i think we forget a lot like a lot of
times we we put people up on a pedestal
like rugby league stars and all that
type of stuff
but when it comes to people that are
actually making a difference and real
super
heroes you know teachers nurses doctors
i'd like i'm glad you're getting a bit
of a
following around what you do because you
know you are making a difference in
in our next generation and so my
testament to you and well done on
getting that top 10
um as well the australia day um speech
mate how did that feel when you were
giving that speech was
nervous yeah look man um i was i was
pretty terrified this is actually
the same year like you mentioned 2018 it
just went bananas i think um
but i guess they say when it rains it
pours i guess it doesn't work in the
other direction as well because it was
an
incredible and busy year um so the
australia day address for people who
don't know
it's kind of um it's on the week of
australia day just just a few days
before
um january 26th and it was it's kind of
this um
opportunity to speak about australian
values um what being australian means to
you
i'm gonna before i tell you what it was
a bit like i'm gonna put you on the spot
luke i'm gonna turn the table
if i if you someone came to you the
premier of new south wales in fact and
said luke
i'd love you to speak for like half an
hour on anything
about what it means for you to be
australian
what do you reckon you talk about like
what themes or what kind of topic would
you address
oh mate yeah thanks for putting me on
the spot eddie
um oh by not the
mateship uh togetherness uh community
um lending a hand they're probably some
of the areas that i would um
i would highlight yeah i think i was
thinking very similar things
and so i kind of um i was given this
brief to talk about the australian
culture and society and my my part in it
and uh i think the first thing was just
you know we talk about imposter syndrome
like i totally felt like who am i to
give this especially given my
sort of background i know this sounds
really weird but it just gives you a
sense of the way i thought about this
when i was growing up
um if my mom had asked me like oh how
many kids are in your what kind of kids
are in your class you know at school i
might have said oh there's like
there's two asian kids um there's an
indian kid there's a couple of
indigenous kids
and then there are like 15 australians
that's the way i would have said it and
what i meant was
um there would have been 15 caucasian or
ango saxon kids
and so that was so deeply ingrained
as a child then actually it took a long
time for me to realize oh
i i am an australian we are australians
and that's part of what makes australian
culture beautiful right but
i i definitely did feel um quite
terrified you know
the governor of new south wales was
there i i had to have a special thing
that i said at the beginning to honor
all the different dignitaries and i was
like yeah okay
this is a big deal man i don't don't
screw this up so i was very nervous to
say the least
did you did you feel like you were did
you you know most people when they go on
stage you know boring you heard the
slogan that you
you just think you imagine everyone
being naked right but did you imagine
your your class your yeah yeah that's
not a bad idea actually because i do
feel like there's this funny thing that
takes over in my brain where i'm in
front of
you know the 30 students in my classroom
or the 24 if it's a senior class
um and it's kind of like these are
people who i know really well they know
me and
you just kind of like ah relax um though
i should i should point out there is
always like the
the safety release valve when i'm when
i'm in front of my classroom
i'm kind of like okay um i'm i'm done
talking i'm gonna get you guys all to do
some exercises like work on some
questions and then i just kind of
sit down and relax a little bit couldn't
do that in front of the premier and the
governor
so um that was a different experience
for sure but it was a privilege
that's so cool and thank you from me on
the spot i can see your teacher coming
out already
hey um how did you become the most
famous math teacher buddy like how did
the journey of
youtube come about and and the the
growth that you've
and the you know the ability of what
you've been able to deliver since
yeah i mean the first thing i can tell
you is it wasn't planned uh you know
i had a friend of mine actually and he a
fellow maths teacher and he's
such a strategic and um you know well
thought out guy he's got like a
spreadsheet for every aspect of his life
he's got a five-year plan he knows his
exact trajectory um and when you can put
me
and him next to each other it's like do
you even know what you're doing with
your life so
a lot of this i stumbled by accident um
but yeah it was back in 2012 so we're
coming up to
eight years ago now feels like a
lifetime ago especially this year
um there was a student of mine and he
was quite unwell so
it's fairly normal procedure when you've
got a student and he might miss
or she might miss class because they are
um they're not they're not healthy or
maybe they're just doing something like
with
uh you know representing the school in
hockey or doing anything that takes them
out of school
we're pretty used to you know preparing
a package of here are the assessments
you're going to miss or here's the
homework
here are the topics that we're going to
address and so to make sure that you
keep up to date and catch up when you
return
to normal right but one of the things
that we knew this particular boy he was
diagnosed with cancer
very very suddenly and so he went
straight into um
chemo radio everything was just going to
completely ravage
his immune system so even when he wasn't
going through treatment
he was not going to be able to be
present at school physically
because yeah we just couldn't be uh you
know we didn't want to infect him or
anything like that
even though he just lived across the
road from us from the school
and so i knew it'd just be heartbreaking
for him to have this real
separation from his peers and everything
that made his experience at school
normal and that's what led me to just
like take the the camera uh in the in my
pocket that was just sitting there i
didn't really know anything about
recording videos but i was like this
thing's a decent camera on it right
and that's where it began and you can
still see those videos you can tell
that i never thought anyone else would
watch them because the first videos are
terrible they're like
sometimes i step out of the frame where
you can't hear me um but i'm amazed that
people actually found them
useful and it's just sort of spiraled
out from there so how
when you say people found them useful
like what was
how did you start to know that what's
going on here
people are watching like when did that
all start happening and was that a
little bit surreal
yeah yeah there there were a few
different moments um i think one of the
ones that really sticked in my mind
because it was just such a weird
um like i was like am i in a movie kind
of moment
um i was actually the shops and i was
just i was just getting dinner for the
family for the evening and i was like oh
what am i gonna get i'm just i'm
standing there in front of the you know
you're at the butcher and all the
different meats are sitting in front of
you you're like oh what should i pick
i think i said to the guy behind the
counter i said i have a couple of kilos
of chicken wings thanks like really
ordinary
order but when i when i asked him he
sort of
um looked at me a bit funny and i didn't
know i didn't know what that was
supposed to mean like oh
sorry is chicken wings not a good thing
sorry i didn't realize i was not the
thing to order at this place so anyway
he he looked at me funny
i just gave him money didn't think about
it and i only came back with my change
like 60 seconds later
he he looked at me again he's like hey
are you a maths teacher and i was kind
of like okay that's
that's a little bit weird and um like i
wasn't dressed like i am now
like i just come home from work so i
just was really perplexed
and i asked him how he knew and he's
like oh yeah i think i've seen videos of
you
so to know that just some random person
who i just bumped into was watching
uh online that's what kind of that was
one of the first things that signaled to
me
wow this is going um broader than i ever
imagined
have you stepped up your uh your camera
quality and your microphone like have
you
yeah actually it's quite quite fun story
i have you know because i did just begin
with my phone
um i eventually sort of upgraded to
upgraded to an ipad because i was trying
to edit on the tiny screen
on my phone and like cut here and i'd
always like miss the right the spot that
i wanted to edit because my fingers are
too stubby
i've had but even then i had some people
say to me hey
um we would really love it if we could
hear more clearly
if we could see your voice sorry i see
the whiteboard more clearly
and things like youtube actually does
automatic captioning which i didn't
realize
until i started doing this and it's
really great for students or anyone who
has hearing disabilities
and they said hey if your audio quality
was better then we can actually
like the automatic captions will be you
know actually useful and so i was like
okay that makes sense actually it's not
just to make it look fancy is to help
more people
so yeah i've got like a substantial
setup now which has grown over the years
is it right that you've been called like
the kim kardashian of mathematics
uh well look um sort of yes i mean this
is one of those things
so adam spencer who's an incredible guy
like
i'm smarter than i am i i met him once
and
he kind of coined this term and i think
it's one of those things where
if you just it doesn't have any basis in
reality but if you just say it enough
times like people will start to think it
so um yeah i don't i don't have like
when i think about kim kardashian i'm
like what is she she's famous for being
famous
um i i don't have it like you know big
hollywood home lots of money that kind
of thing
i think i'm almost as far away from kim
k as you can imagine
um but yeah if what i'm helping people
do is notice
um teachers mainstream culture then i
guess i'll give a thumbs up to that
well in in you just said you just nailed
it on its head you love being a teacher
like you don't
you've got you want to always be a
teacher right this is not about
fame for you this is this is about
um yeah why are you doing what you're
doing yeah 100
i mean um i i love being in the
classroom and i think
um you know one of the reasons why i've
you know like you mentioned in the intro
i've written
some books and i've you know hosted a tv
series and all those things are really
they're all about serving learning like
helping people
um embrace learning and and not view
that as something like we have to do or
something that we dislike doing
but actually something that enriches
life and helps us understand the world
better and
and contribute to society more
effectively for me
that's what learning and being a teacher
is all about so everything i do is
in service of that mate i love that too
you know i struggled with maths when i
was
when i was going through school you know
i knew the basics but
you know things like pythagoras theorem
and all the rest of it
just went straight over my head when
we're talking in the pre-chat you you
you make it you make those um
equations something that people can
understand and making it normalized is
that
is that a good way of assessing it yeah
i think that is a nice summary actually
one of the um
one of the superpowers of mathematics is
that
it sort of can apply to all kinds of
different things um you know when we
think about
obviously hard to ignore right the
elephant in the room in this
covert world that we live in um i don't
think there's ever been
a time throughout history that we've
been so obsessed with numbers
and graphs and mathematical models of
when's the right time to reopen our
economy or be able to start like
when does it when's the economic
break-even point for
planes to start flying again all of
these things are governed by mathematics
but then it's it's not just that it's
also
you know biology is immensely
mathematical um the economy that i've
talked about before engineering like
we've sent
human beings to the moon all of that was
done through mathematics
so that's awesome right mathematics is
flexible in this way
but the upshot of that is that i think
when and i saw in the in the poll that
you posted before you know a lot of
people
probably from school weren't enjoying
mathematics it was a very abstract thing
to them like the x's and y's
because they could stand for anything
they kind of meant
nothing right it's like i don't know
they're just on a page so i feel like a
big part of my role
is to connect those abstract ideas to
something concrete and often that's what
helps students engage they're like ah
now it connects to my life something i'm
interested in and that's why i put the
effort in to learn it
that's awesome mate i love that as well
uh so talk to me you've got another book
coming out is that right
eddie yeah so um i wrote
my first book um woo's wonderful world
of maths which is just super cheesy name
for a chubby cheesy person
um i kind of had to tell you why buddy
know your brand
yeah exactly i'm embracing it man that's
who i am so i wrote that book for two
particular kinds of people number one
i'm a high school teacher so i kind of
pictured
like your average sort of 15 year old
teenager
because when i teach in school in my
classroom like i've been asked hundreds
and thousands of times like
sir why do we have to learn this like
what's the point um and i've come up
with lots of different
answers to that question like the kinds
of things i was just saying just now
real life contexts where you might be
surprised
to find mathematics hiding underneath
there right so every chapter of that
book
was um designed to tell a story that
that shows mathematics in a surprising
place
that was the first audience teenagers
but the other audience is what i would
call
a mathematically disenfranchised adult
you know someone who left maths
behind many years ago um and kind of
knew like oh i said
sure maybe maybe some people on on this
channel i don't know how to add up two
lattes and a piccolo and that's pretty
much it
so i i wanted people like that to pick
up this book not be intimidated by it
there's lots of pictures it's a very
visual thing
um but when i wrote that book one of the
things that delighted me most um but
really
made me realize i've got a lot of work
to do is and lots of younger kids or
parents of younger kids said hey do you
have anything
for us for like kids who are in primary
school or or just like
learning to read and wanting to like
engage with activities and something
practical
and so that's where um yeah these
children's activities books were born so
anyways mathematics is coming out um oh
it's
like the 21st today isn't it so um we're
about a week away from a release day
amazing well i'll put it into the office
area anyway because i think you can
can't you so so if you uh
want to get eddie's new book then please
make sure you click on that
and purchase it in your own time uh mate
we're gonna we've got a fair few
questions coming through and please do
ask questions i've told eddie that if we
go over we go over
i can wait buddy um but before we get
into that it's been a really tough year
for um students this year especially
around
sort of covid and we're just chatting
about it before that you know like year
12
um finishing up very shortly as well
like how has the year been for
for the kids there at cherry brook and
and from what you've done
yeah i mean i myself teach a year 12
class so i've been saying to them you
know i do a lot of the normal things
that i would preparing students for
you know that final set of exams and you
know stress is running high and i think
a lot of them have this sense of
you know how much their future rides on
how they go
in these exams and one of the things i
have to remind them is hey man you are
not defined by a number like you are so
much more than your atar and encouraging
them in that way
um but i think that you know so much
more than that
you know they're going through they're
living through this historic time um i
was talking to them actually because
several of them i i think about you know
you and me would probably remember
where we were on september 11 2001 right
this is something like you know the
world changed and we remember like
before then and after then
and i said to to my my classes right
you're gonna look back on 2020
sort of in a similar way like it was the
year of the pandemic or maybe it'll be a
couple of years who knows how long this
is going to last
and so yeah the the it's been tough to
support them through that
um but i'm also like i think we often
forget um
we don't give you know young people
enough credit to see their resilience
that there's
if they've responded to this i've been
so amazed by the way that
not only are they just sort of looking
themselves and realizing this has been
tough
but they've also had an amazing eye for
social justice and awareness of the
bigger challenges being faced by people
around the world because of this
condition we're all in so
they're amazing that's why i love
working with young people and they're
going to be
amazing citizens whatever they get in
their final exams so it's great playing
a small part in their journey out of um
out of school well they're definitely
going to be more conscious about the
world around them and that's for sure so
unlike some of us oldies oneself um now
buddy
uh let's ask a few questions uh
i'm gonna pick this one here damien
clark my teacher always told me that
you'll never have a calculator or
encyclopedia
in your pocket how do you teach children
respect the process
of learning versus applying the
information instantly available in their
pocket that's a very good question
damien
nailed it really [ __ ] i love it and it's
um yeah it's true you know um
it's a bit of a laugh when it used to be
a reason where like you'll need to know
your times tables because you won't
always be able to just pull the
calculator out it's like huh well we
showed them
having the sum total of human knowledge
accessible in our pockets
in some ways i reckon that is it's not
less of a reason to be able to respect
learning i think it's more of a reason
this year these last few years have
taught us that we don't just have access
to um you know the world's information
we also have access to all this
miss information and no one necessarily
like weighs a red flag and tells you hey
this is not reliable information
hey i'm actually showing you this graph
that has been designed to
sort of play things up or play things
down and so i think that just shows
all the more reason why like from a
mathematical point of view
i want to be able to scrutinize the
statistics that someone says to me you
know when it's an election year people
like 75 percent of the population do
this or
we predict that models show you know
whatever is going to happen in the
future
and if we do not have um the grounding
and the learning to be able to say
hmm can i critique that is that really
true is that really plausible
i think we're kind of going into the
world without hands and feet
to be able to understand and interpret
the deluge of information
that we're all kind of living in today
it's trying to find that right
information too because there's so many
different
variations of info out there that um
yeah
rachel's got a great question as well i
teach primary school with a particular
interest in maths
i see kids with who have developed mass
anxiety from quite a young age
why do you think kids have such anxiety
around maths
and how do you combat it in your
classroom wow great question um the
first thing i will do
um before i answer uh your question
rachel is i will tip my hat to you
because
i have so much respect for primary
school teachers i
i find it challenging enough just to
wrap my head around my own one subject
let alone like eight or nine
um if you haven't thought about that for
our friends out there who are not yeah
it's like they just have to know the
whole you know
spectrum of different subjects and that
their students will ask them questions
about they have to teach
so rachel you have a huge task ahead of
you and that that anxiety that you
mentioned
um yeah it's real like there's a lot of
different um things in there
i think for example um one of the things
which i think is most dangerous
is that when teaching and learning
mathematics and i know like i'm going to
put my hand up
mathematics teachers are largely not
entirely but largely responsible for
what i'm about to say
um we often emphasize um speed and
accuracy
right it's like oh you're good at maths
we'll give you like a stamp or a sticker
if you can finish all your questions
fast if you do your time tables fast and
if you get everything right don't make
any mistakes right
there's only a big problem with that
which is that actually real
mathematicians number one
are notoriously slow thinkers actually
it's not about being able to
access answers quickly it's actually
about slowing down and asking really
good questions the questions that no one
has ever thought of asking before
that's what makes a great mathematician
so i think the emphasis on speed is a
is one thing and then you know when we
reward students for only ever get things
right we miss the fact that all great
mathematicians make progress
and um you know help us learn things
that everyone in society benefits from
from getting things wrong and then being
able to learn something from that right
so if you think about our children and
like every time they do something slowly
or every time they make a mistake we're
like no we scold them or we you know
even if we don't scold them but we just
reward all the people who are quick and
accurate
i think we're giving them a a sort of
wrong image of what mathematics is and
we breed that anxiety
so i think in my class you know there's
no such thing
as a wrong answer usually it's the right
answer to a different question and so
helping my students
see that and say you know your
contributions to this class are valued
in a discussion i'm not going to say
ah luke that was wrong i'm not taught
you anything like what a way to
discourage a kid right
totally is very important love it uh
felicity's ass who influenced your love
for mass
of mass felicity a bunch of different
people i feel very lucky that i've had
some great mentors
um throughout my life when it comes to
mathematics um
if i had to pick one it would just be my
brother actually because
you know going back to rachel's question
before i wasn't particularly gifted at
maths when i was younger or i'm still
not
um but when i was younger what sort of
i'm clued me into thinking there's
something worth
looking at here was that my brother
always he just embraced mathematics in a
really
creative and wonderful way one of the
first things he showed a computer
a commodore 64. if any if that means
anything to anyone out there really old
yeah classic right um he actually used
it to
create this mathematical artwork just
just
pause on that idea for a second a
mathematical artwork i didn't even know
such a thing existed and so
for him for me rather he sort of taught
me that there's more to math and just
crunching numbers and you know solving
problems it's about being creative as
well so
i i owe him a debt of gratitude in that
way i love that so
um samantha's asked how do we keep our
year 11 and 12 kids motivated in their
schoolwork especially here in melbourne
my son is in year 11 and it's tough he
hasn't been in school since term two
remote learning he loves remote learning
but it's not ideal
is it just the situation right now like
yeah what's your thoughts
yeah i'm definitely all there i mean a
lot of people kind of look at me and
they're like oh you're the person who's
all about technology and using video
for your learning all that kind of thing
and i sort of am but because i'm so
familiar with this
space and the technology i also know
what it's not good at
what it is good at and definitely that
social aspect is hugely missing so
maybe that's kind of my tip i know it is
not the same by any stretch
from being in the community of learners
that is a classroom every single day
um but i think one of the things that we
forget is you know if i'm working on a
problem and i don't really get it
like the first thing i will do is just
turn to the person next to me and say
hey
hey what did you do for this right and
that's kind of an instinct and that
actually
drives our learning and for not just me
who who benefits from the person who
helps me
but even from the person who maybe gives
me the explanation that actually
helps develop their understanding too um
it was a physicist richard feynman who
said
you do not understand something truly
until you can explain it
simply and i think it's really really
deep right and so
i think one of the ways we can help keep
motivated for these year 11 is 12
students
is to use technology in as innovative
ways as we can to keep on connecting
with others maybe
like schedule a 15 minute like hey let's
just catch up and just look at
what we've been learning today let's
just no plan let's just talk through it
and i think that would have really
unexpected benefits because of that
collaborative aspect to learning that's
so important that we're missing at the
moment
love it uh we'll do two more questions
mate what do you think about australia
having not enough teachers but also the
consensus that teacher
quality is low how do you think we
should be addressing this because
you work in the public system correct i
do yeah i
am have been in public schools all
through my life and i went through them
as a kid and then now have always taught
them the last
12 or 13 years um look these are these
are really tough realities right and i i
think both of those things are
categorically true we do not have in
particular subject areas
enough teachers it's it's hugely
problematic especially in some of the
areas that
um society is really hurting for you
know we have a world that's built on
on science and engineering and those are
the areas where you know if you want to
you know make money in the world and
have a have a you know a decent job then
you would go into those fields rather
than to teach those fields but that's
kind of self-eating for our society
right if we don't
form a great foundation for our young
people so that's problematic i mean when
we talk about teacher quality
i i know what people mean in that you
know the quality of what's happening in
the classroom
and um you know the actual nature of
teaching is is something that struggles
but i think it's really important as
well to identify and to say to policy
makers and and decision makers
that a lot of the reason why that is a
challenge is because
now more than ever particularly the last
10 to 15 years
teachers are expected to do much more
than just teaching the classroom
teachers are kind of expected to be you
know psychologists
and social workers and health workers as
well
the responsibility that they bear on
their shoulders is immense and that's
why something has to give like we still
have the same 24 hours a day
to plan and prepare and support our
students that we always had so
i think it's really important that
society recognizes the roles that we're
asking educators to actually shoulder
and provide the support that they need
as well
i think a lot of parents learned that
during kobe when they had to do
homeschooling tonight
um uh amy last question eddie i love
your energy as a teacher who is new
to the profession how do you maintain
such a high level of energy whilst
teaching especially when teaching online
oh wow yeah no brilliant question and
amy i'm so glad
um that you're tuning in i it still
feels not that long ago that i was a
very early career teacher
and did not know what i was doing at all
and that was kind of
yeah i think for me you know to answer
your question most um
directly two things i would say number
one you gotta look after yourself
like the numbers around um early career
teacher attrition right like 50
of teachers leaving the profession in
the first five years
wow that's terrific right that's really
awful um and it's because we we sort of
burn ourselves out looking out for
ourselves we've got to look out for
ourselves
teaching is it's a marathon it's a long
game right um you've gotta
i'm gonna get my cup here right you
gotta look out for yourself and make
sure your well-being is important this
is um by the way
this is my uh it's sort of a cup it's
actually half of my bottle because i'm
drinking water constantly
um that's that's part of the way i look
after myself as a teacher otherwise i
just go horse
so you gotta look after yourself in
order to be someone who can
give to the profession for 25 30 years i
hope you do that amy
um but the other thing you know like in
terms of like how do i bring energy
it comes back to one word um and that's
purpose right like
why am i missed why am i putting hours
into
understanding this really tough gnarly
idea in mathematics so i can explain it
clearly
why am i you know writing reports for my
students to give their parents feedback
to
keep them part of this education process
the purpose
is my students learning and the fact
that i have this responsibility to help
prepare my students not just to learn
some formulas
but to actually go out into the world as
responsible citizens you can give back
to their communities in society
that's massively important and when you
have that importance and that dignity of
your work
at the front of your mind i find that's
what motivates me to give it my best and
to always bring my a game because my
students absolutely deserve it
mate uh wow that was incredible buddy
and um
no wonder you're in the top 10 teachers
in the world buddy um
that was that was truly inspirational i
think everyone's got a lot out of today
can everyone please give a wave of
gratitude
to eddie in the chat room today we'll
send him all the chat log as well so he
can read through all your notes
he's been talking with us today also
please make sure you join us tomorrow we
have the incredible
friends two mates that started a
business called orange sky
um no just sorry i'm just gonna orange
sky laundry
um these guys are incredible they've
been helping out homeless people
stay clean um we've got washing machines
and showers in the back of their vans
we've got over 40 odd vans now across
australia and they're
they're on a quest for 116 000 homeless
people to be looked after and stay clean
so
please make sure you join us tomorrow by
clicking into the office area
and registering your details for another
fantastic morning eddie
you have been incredible this morning
thank you so much for joining us in the
cupper of live cafe
any parting words for the people on
board
yeah look i i'd say to everyone out
there um especially to those people
i assume there are going to be many
parents who are watching and um this
year has had
an impact on them learning wise for
their kids um i guess i would say
um be kind to yourself it is hugely
confronting you're like man i'm trying
to do my own work from home and also
support my kids
um you you are not meant to be a
replacement for your kids teacher
that is our task but you certainly can
be a co-learner beside your children
helping them to to motivate them and say
hey let's learn something together so
don't worry if you're not the expert
we're all going to get through this year
together and just thanks everyone for
joining us this morning
so good eddie i will be sending out a
follow-up email for the appropriate
links as well and also links to his word
tube channel give it a follow
give him an extra 60 odd 40 60 70 odd
new followers
uh mate thank you so much for joining us
on with your day and uh yeah
i really do appreciate your time cheers
bye